the frame matters more than the picture
what's that mean I think often in life
whether it's marketing or innovation or
when we're building companies or
products or making content we fall into
the Trap of thinking that the thing
we're creating in and of itself is doing
all of the work to tell the story but
when I looked at tons of studies when I
looked at apples and art galleries it's
so clear that much of the work is being
done in Psychology not in reality if we
just think about the Apple Store every
electronic store you've ever walked into
in your life is kind of like a crazy
Jungle of wires right that's how
electronic stores always were what Apple
did differently was they gave the iPhone
space in the shop so the space that the
object is given actually pours into the
value of the object itself because it
has 2 feet either side of it the frame
in which it's presented is telling you
that this item in the middle is high
value the context you've always seen
that kind of framing in is an art
gallery the other thing I think so
critical is they only show you one of
each device and they keep the rest in
the back room if we think about scarcity
creating value the frame in which you
present something is doing so much of
the work to communicate the value of the
thing within it